[Música]
y
cuántos de ustedes creen que hoy pueden
ser una enfermedad que en poco menos de
un mes para acabar con sus vidas o con
la de sus seres más queridos
hace un año viví uno de los momentos más
difíciles de la vida humana la muerte
en menos de dos meses perdí tres de las
personas más importantes de mi vida
estaba pasando por una perdida sintiendo
el dolor de esta pérdida y ya estaba
viendo es más
estas tres personas fueron detectadas
tardíamente diferentes enfermedades
cuando si ustedes creen que hoy
realmente pueden ser uno de ellos
si no lo saben pues creo que los médicos
de cabecera ni siquiera podrían saberlo
si en esta charla fuéramos mil personas
alrededor de 560 y nosotros podríamos
ser una enfermedad crónica y no ser
detectados a tiempo entonces cuando koné
la enfermedad llegó más cerca que nunca
a mi vida y la muerte también empecé a
cuestionarme todo lo que hacía una de
las preguntas que más me llenaba de
miedo y me frustraba muchísimo era quien
sería esa siguiente persona sería mi
hermana sería mi pareja sería yo como
podría estar segura de que las cosas
iban a ser diferentes a las que estaba
viviendo en ese momento y que no iba a
escuchar cosas iguales a la que nos
decían los médicos que era por haber
sido diferente si hubiera detectado a
tiempo
porque no se le dice este tratamiento si
lo hubiéramos probado todo sería
completamente distinto o porque nunca se
le hizo ese examen ahora es demasiado
tarde y que de pronto iba a escuchar
unas respuestas que fueran muchísimo más
alentadoras y reales que me dan
soluciones
que pudiera seguir entonces si se dan
cuenta todas las frases que les acaba de
mencionar son muy muy reveladoras te
dicen claramente que el sistema de salud
tiene un gap inmenso a la hora de hacer
las cosas a tiempo que pueda tratar
realmente al paciente y que pueda salvar
la vida a este
la evolución si ustedes miran atrás la
evolución de la medicina nos ha traído
un sinfín de avances en cuanto a los
tratamientos en cuanto a nuevas
moléculas en cuanto la atención al
paciente y ser muchísimo más reactivos a
la hora de
enfrentar la salud sin embargo el exceso
y el alto volumen de pacientes que hoy
tenemos en el mundo el crecimiento
desbordado de nuevas enfermedades y la
alta carga que hoy tenemos
administrativa en el sistema de salud en
particular ha hecho que nos
desconectamos por completo de lo que hoy
es el médico con el paciente y más allá
de eso de lo que hace lo que vemos y
vivimos como pacientes con nuestra
propia salud lo que ha dado como
resultado es que hoy el sistema sea
completamente reactivo y nada preventivo
hoy
35.8 millones de personas mueren en el
mundo por no ser diagnosticadas a tiempo
por otro lado el
65% del tiempo que nosotros destinamos a
una consulta médica está hecha para
hacer procesos administrativos y hacer
una revisión de datos dejando menos de
15 minutos
valiosos para la atención al paciente y
por otro lado ese enorme volumen de
pacientes enfermos ha generado un gap a
la hora de tener acceso a la salud
la cual hace que al menos la mitad de la
población mundial hoy no tenga servicios
esenciales en salud
anteriormente como se cedían las cosas y
la labor fundamental del médico era
centrar su trabajo en tener una buena
relación con el paciente el evaluaba ese
factor biológico de la mano de los
factores socioeconómicos y emocionales
para realmente entender que era lo que
estaba pasando con él entonces el médico
se dedicaba a entender sus dolencias
pero también a entender sus problemas y
sus deseos más allá del espacio clínico
entonces esa evaluación biológica y esa
evaluación socioeconómica emocional
tenían igual peso a la hora de evaluar y
generar un tratamiento óptimo para el
paciente
esa calidad humana esa conexión esa
interacción con el paciente médico es la
que hoy hemos perdido
gracias a todos esos excesos que
mencionaba anteriormente y la ciencia de
datos precisamente es buena en esto nos
permite que tengamos una salud mucho más
humana y que volvamos a reconectar para
generar soluciones mucho más oportunas y
mejores para el paciente
hace poco creando una solución para una
rueda hospitalario aquí conocí una
empresa una aseguradora en salud que
hace precisamente esto volver la salud
parte del día a día de las personas
entonces ellos lo que encontraron es que
la ciencia de datos hace mucho más
cercana al paciente con su salud y al
médico con la salud del paciente así
como cuando ustedes se van de compras
que es un proceso realmente sencillo es
una tarea muy tranquila que hace parte
de tu vida asimismo en la ciencia de
datos hace que lo podamos hacer en la
salud que sea igual donde no solamente
es reactivo cuando estamos enfermos o
cuando estamos muriendo como normalmente
sucede sino que por el contrario en la
base consciente y lo hace parte de
nuestro día a día
esto aseguraba entonces lo que hizo fue
entender cuáles eran sus principales
problemas y encontró que uno de ellos es
que la lenta reacción que tiene el
sistema de salud para atender esta
cantidad de pacientes ha hecho que el
75% de ellos sientan insatisfacción y
poca credibilidad del sistema
simplemente porque no se sienten parte y
sienten que no hay derechos para él en
la industria de la salud y por otro lado
encontraron que el 65 por ciento de esa
labor que ellos tenían médica o no
médica de su labor diaria estaba
destinada a procesos repetitivos que no
tenían nada que ver con la labor médica
en la cual ellos estaban enfocados
entonces lo que decidieron hacer en este
caso fue hacer es un proceso
implementación donde el 65 por ciento de
estas actividades que eran repetitivas y
fuera de la labor médica pudieran ser
automatizadas y optimizadas para con el
fin de que todo estuviera centrado en la
experiencia humano y en el proceso en el
centro estuviera el paciente como en
todo el proceso de ideación
entonces lo que hicieron y los
resultados que tuvieron ellos luego
hacer
y mentación con estos modelos de
inteligencia artificial de ciencia de
datos fue que primero aumentaron la
credibilidad en sus pacientes en sus
asegurados segundo destinaron el 85% de
todas sus consultas con los pacientes a
tener una atención más cercana humana
que atendiera sus dolencias biológicas y
hacer una profunda investigación de su
comportamiento del día a día de cuánto
hábitos no solamente en el espacio
clínico sino fuera de este espacio
clínico por otro lado lo que hacían era
unir ese equipo médico con el equipo
operativo donde el equipo operativo lo
que hacía es hacer como todo un análisis
de lo que estaba pasando con el paciente
y hacer una trazabilidad incluso antes
de que asistiera a la parte médica oa
las a las instituciones médicas y por
último todo esto lo unían con
herramientas tecnológicas que les
permitía optimizar procesos automatizar
procesos y encontrar hallazgos que
fueran relevantes para el médico tomar
decisiones en tiempo real y enfocar
hacia un modelo muchísimo más preventivo
los resultados entonces fueron fabulosos
aumentaron este 85% y además de eso
optimizaron el net promoter score que es
de esa métrica que mide que tanto los
asegurados a sus clientes recomiendan a
otros pues a esta empresa lo que
tuvieron fue un 90 por ciento de puntaje
esto quiere decir que que tanto le
pueden recomendar ustedes a sus hijos
que vayan a disney para que ellos se
diviertan
dicho esto creo que ninguno de nosotros
realmente está preparado para escuchar
decir que es demasiado tarde y que no
hay nada que hacer por un paciente por
un hijo por una esposa por una madre que
morirá que ya no hay nada que hacer y
que se
así de frío y así de cruel lo más
interesante de la ciencia de datos es
que permite ver esto con tiempo para que
no sea demasiado tarde salvar la vida de
las personas que amamos permite
identificar patrones que son relevantes
para identificarla ante la enfermedad
con antelación y aumentar esa tasa de
supervivencia
el problema más grande con los sistemas
de detección actual que existen es que
primero son muy costosos son poco
escalables es decir muy pocas personas
realmente tienen acceso y requiere de
una capacidad de una infraestructura
instalada a la que pocos países como
colombia tenemos acceso entonces hace
poco una organización mundial en salud
se acercó a nosotros y nos pidió ayuda
para crear un modelo de detección
temprana de leucemia linfocítica
este tipo de enfermedad además de ser
una de las enfermedades que más matan
niños en el mundo es muy difícil su
proceso de diagnóstico en las etapas
iniciales lo cual reduce el porcentaje
de supervivencia en estos pacientes
entonces imagínense que ustedes tienen
un hijo si su hijo tiene leucemia y es
detectado en un país como eeuu tiene una
probabilidad de sobrevivir del 80 por
ciento por el otro lado si tienen un
detectado en un país como colombia se
reduce a la mitad de esta cifra es decir
tiene una probabilidad de sobrevivir de
el 40 por ciento y si es detectado en
las enfermedades en la etapa tardía de
la enfermedad se reduce a la mitad es
decir si de su hijo tiene leucemia es
detectado en un país como colombia o
cualquier país de la región y es
detectado tardíamente esta probabilidad
de sobrevivir se reduce a menos del 25
por ciento
cómo se sienten ustedes como padres
cuando escuchan decir listo
lo que hicimos entonces fue crear un
modelo de inteligencia artificial que
pudiera analizar imágenes de células
donde detectaba linfocitos sanos y
enfermos creamos un modelo entrenamos un
modelo con múltiples imágenes miles de
imágenes que creara múltiples algoritmos
y entregara uno en término óptimo en
términos de precisión en tan sólo 48
horas tuvimos un resultado de un modelo
que nos arrojó 92 por ciento de
precisión normalmente este tipo de este
tipo de modelos puede entregar
y resultados en menos de cinco minutos
y actualmente los médicos que analizan
esta información dependiendo de la
variabilidad diagnóstica que tenga cada
uno de ellos puede disminuir o puede
aumentar entre 1 a 2 días y luego pasar
un informe para que el paciente pueda
volver y entregar los resultados de la
enfermedad
entonces este tipo de investigación lo
que ha hecho es que primero aumente la
probabilidad de que el médico pueda
tomar decisiones en tiempo real para
ayudar al paciente y además le permite
aliviar la carga de la enfermedad
este modelo en particular calculamos que
podamos reducir el tiempo de diagnóstico
de la etapa 3 de la enfermedad a la
etapa 1 llevando como resultado que se
pueda aumentar ese porcentaje de
supervivencia a un 75 por ciento
así es como la ciencia datos hace que
sea más humano la salud podemos unir el
médico con ese conocimiento humano para
que realmente podamos ser preventivos
detectar a tiempo enfermedades y poder
ayudar al paciente
haciendo está haciendo esta charla creo
que realmente vale fuertemente la idea
de que la ciencia datos y poder ver más
humana la salud
con la persona con la que decidí
compartir mi vida lleva meses sino años
yendo intentando ser diagnosticado de
una condición muy extraña que él tiene y
en los últimos meses hemos asistido más
de 17 especialistas
en los cuales nunca nos han dado como
una respuesta clara simplemente nos
mandan más exámenes y más exámenes y no
nos dicen como nada concreto la última
doctora fue completamente distinto ella
nos llamó con antelación nos pidió el
favor de que miramos todo su historia
clínica de él y que además llenaremos un
formulario con cosas que le pasaban con
preguntas que a él le sucedían en su día
a día a sus deseos sus emociones sus
problemas en que trabajaba etcétera
cuando llegamos a la consulta fue
supremamente interesante porque la
consulta estuvo destinada a que
tuviéramos una conversación muy fluida
supremamente empática y que cuando lo
examinó pudiera darnos resultados en
tiempo real de lo que estaba pasando con
el cuerpo lo que hizo básicamente ella
fue meter hacer una analítica dato es
muy sencilla donde metió toda la
información médica junto con la
información de su día a día emocional y
toda la que acaba de mencionar y
encontró patrones importantes que
estaban dándole indicios de que podría
suceder con su cuerpo y que pasos hacia
adelante podríamos construir en menos de
dos horas lo que había sido tedioso por
años y estos últimos meses nos dio
muchísima claridad y nos dio esperanza
con la posibilidad de ayuda a ayudarlo a
mejorar su calidad de vida y que ya no
sintiera más dolor y me lleno a mí de
tranquilidad de no verlo sufrir lo cual
es algo invaluable
para mí
entonces así es como la ciencia datos
hacia la salud más humana de nuevo creo
firmemente que este tipo de herramientas
junto al conocimiento médico o de
cualquier profesional en salud ayuda a
que reencauce moss nuestros
conocimientos como humanos volvamos a
que sea más humano en la salud
encontremos hallazgos que son
importantes para que no sea demasiado
tarde para salvar la vida de las
personas que amamos
entonces creo firmemente en que la
ciencia de datos de la mano del
conocimiento médico permite reencausar
el conocimiento de los profesionales de
salud para enfocarse en lo que realmente
es importante en mejorar la experiencia
humana en cuanto a la atención del
paciente prevenir realmente este tipo de
enfermedades y detectarlas a tiempo
cuando es cuando es posible salvar la
vida de estos
estamos a tan solo una decisión de
implementar este tipo de herramientas en
nuestro sistema que nos permite ayudarle
a miles de colombianos que hoy lo
necesitan y que cuando lleguemos allí
podamos crecer a muchísimos más hasta el
día en que finalmente podamos decir que
nadie en la tierra morirá a causa de
enfermedades que nosotros podemos tratar
pero que no están siendo detectados a
tiempo
por último quiero recordarles que la
salud no lo es todo pero si no tenemos
no no tenemos nada
y es un derecho que debemos darlo y
construirlo para todos nuestros
ciudadanos muchísimas gracias
[Música]